hey guys and welcome to episode 112 of
the let's play I realized that it's been
almost a week since I lost uploaded an
episode and I'm very sorry about that
I've just been quite busy in life I do
hope that in the next upcoming weeks
I'll be able to release a bit more
videos because lately I've just had many
things to do I've also been streaming
roller-coaster can three more so than
I've been making videos and streaming
means that I am working on many projects
that I would like to show at some point
maybe but not really projects that I
turn into videos so that's really the
thing I have been playing rollercoaster
can three still but just haven't been
able to upload videos of it
but in the next coming weeks I mean I'm
gonna have exams next week and after
that I'll pretty much be free for a tiny
bit of time
so hopefully I should be able to make
some more videos after that in any case
this video is going to actually feature
the tour of the park it's gonna be a
small tour and I'll just quickly go over
the things which over which I've already
shown in the earlier tour and focus more
on the things which actually new and my
plans of the park but before I hand into
that I still wanted to make this log
flume look a bit more inviting a really
big problem which I had with this log
flume for quite a while is that it's so
incredibly large it's it's that very
large lake which it swims in but it
doesn't really have any scenery around
that to make the log flume more inviting
more of a nice place to be and I suppose
I wanted to do it the silver at way of
making something look nice that is lots
of scenery and flowers to make it look
as inviting as possible and also
something which I wanted to do is to get
more trees in here I really felt like
this was the only way for me to do it
here since this is a log flume which
swims around in a lake and this makes it
very hard to actually have more compact
scenery since I am pretty much forced to
have this very large lake since I need
it for the CT artists women since it
doesn't come with its own water but
obviously you do end up with a large
lake that is very open and cold looking
and that's why I wanted to have more
trees flower
and general foliage over here and that's
pretty much what's happening also you
might have noticed that I have a couple
of empty planters which I might get back
to in the tour of the park but there is
actually a bit of an issue lately I have
actually reinstalled some sets which
I've already had but gone to newer
versions but the newer version of n7
ornamental tree actually removes the
cypress tree which is my favorite tree
in the pack I've talked with in7 about
this but he doesn't like the tree I beg
to differ it's an amazing tree but it
basically means that I need to re
reinstall a couple of sets to get my old
stuff back and repair some things in the
park other than that though this area is
almost fine and I don't think there are
too many issues with it
really the only thing which I'm still
looking into is how to make this log
flume especially over here with this
section in front of the station how to
make it look more comfortable because
right now it just is very open and cold
looking I think and it's gonna be
especially hard in front of the station
over here because I do still want to
have the station be visible from the
pathway on the other side and I do also
want to be there I want to have the rest
of the ride I could be visible from that
pathway but obviously I do have some
sort of State some sort of scenery over
there
so really I'm just hoping that'll sort
itself out in later episodes because at
the moment I have to be very blunt about
this I don't really have too much of a
planning for this Park it's generally
gonna be just opening it see whatever I
feel like doing or what I can do and
just roll with it which is quite a
dangerous strategy and I don't always
apply but at the moment I just feel like
doing it and that's what I enjoy most in
the game so it's gonna be that again for
a little while before I work on the dark
ride in the english area but that is
also something that I should definitely
get back to in the tour of the park
which will be in a second because I'll
be done with this time lapse right here
so let's go alright so here we are by
the way quick notice to prepare for a
lag storm you don't notice the lag since
I time-lapse my videos and speed them up
by quite a bit but even so the FPS of
the time-lapse
is not even that high and I've been able
to get framed rate frame frame rate
drops of 2 fps in the game and sometimes
it runs steadily on 5 to 6 fps
I'm very sorry about that rollercoaster
country is just a bit poorly optimized
and there's already a lot on this pike
so it's somebody I can't really do
anything about in any case here is the
entrance area which I am still thinking
about redoing because the pathways in my
opinion are not really what I want to
have I am happy about the way that the
entrance building looks though though I
am still planning as well to have a
little road over here maybe a ticket
building whenever I feel like and
actually have some sort of system that
would actually work to buy tickets and
then I would probably want to have
turnstiles in the middle of this passage
I don't know why I don't have them yet
it's probably got to do with these
pillars and not really working out in
any case then you enter the park right
over here and here is the Main Street
there is the frame drop by the way
excellent and these buildings are sort
of functionalist they don't really have
anything in them here are some missing
cypress trees by the way but they are
generally I think there'll be shops and
restaurants I still need to get signs
for them to make them feel a bit more
alive
like some small ice cream signs or names
of restaurants for example but I need to
work in that in the future it's a couple
of missing trolley tracks over here and
then this is the rest of the Main Street
it's pretty inviting looking I do
believe I do kind of like it I did get
the bakery over here but other than that
there isn't really anything else and
from that we go to the flying I mean the
chair swing that's that's what the name
is go away stupid thing
it is currently still floating because
I'm missing that base and it will
definitely not be black but I've got
some major hit books issues with that
thing so that I'll be fixed later on and
after that you move into the Spanish
area at the moment which is I'm still
not actually sure if I want to do it
that way but supposedly this would be
the Italian area but honestly it would
also fit into Spain so I think I'm just
going to call this entire area Spain and
get that over with where we've basically
got this little restaurant over here
a very small teacups right over here
because the big teacups ride is of
course reserved for the English area and
some very madrid asked facades over here
a couple of days should still be
finished though and i do not add some
more details to they used to make them
feel more alive and it's a little ride
that's very hidden behind everything but
it's a ride that i get in all of my
parks almost and here's the log flume
itself which is pretty much the
centerpiece and major weeny of this area
a couple of things also to fix is the
fact that this clock has a terrible run
Edison so I need to look at that again
and I think otherwise actually it's a
pretty good area I do a net of course at
some more scenery over here and then
from that we go to Holland which I'm
sorry Dutch people but this is a
transition area it's just very small it
doesn't have any attractions other than
a train station over there and it's
generally it's just quite small well I
do like the way it looks actually think
it's the verse for the most realistic
area in terms of how the the everything
looks actually I was about to say the
architecture but the bridge which by the
way the bridge and the windmill made my
piece of the stage have full credit to
him for that because they look they look
absolutely amazing and really helped to
make this area look more Dutch but yeah
overall I think this has got an
amazingly touch atmosphere and I do like
the station it's a it's a good weeny for
this area even though the windmills also
sort of a weenie
it's rot any more of them more of the
weenie I suppose this is more of a
centerpiece but that's very off-topic
let's stop that okay so the next area is
gonna be English area which I'm still
currently working on and pretty much
what I have over here is a B and I'm
stand up which still needs a CT on it's
currently an in-game thing but that'll
be changed later on there is a small
ferris wheel which should be like the
London Eye or something like that but it
really isn't
there's the teacup ride of course
because how can I not have tea related
things in the English area and this
building over here with the clock tower
that is very much like Big Ben but isn't
exactly like it is going to be a dark
ride and that's pretty much it that's
pretty much the park at the moment I
have nothing else to show the only
current plans the
I have you can tell by the color of the
ground over here this is going to be the
Alpine area I might still what stop that
I might still expand that this is going
to be the German area and Alpine and
German will be sort of interchangeable
especially in terms of their
architecture I might actually merge them
and move the German area away from this
area to maybe have a small Baltic or
Scandinavian part of the park but that
is still something that I would like to
think about for the future and nothing
is still certain about that until I
actually finish what I currently am
working on and yeah that's it at the
moment so I've got nothing else to say I
hope you've all enjoyed this video and
next time I'll just continue working on
this Park and seeing what I can do so
see you then guys